fourth player to have his number retired
by the Miami Heat and that happened on
March 25th joining Shaq Tim Hardaway and
Alonzo Mourning he's Chris Bosh who
joins us they former Miami Heat forward
good morning Chris how are you I'm doing
well how are you I'm doing okay how's
the jumper it's pretty good it's pretty
solid
yeah that's never done anywhere yeah you
know what I mean it's like riding a bike
but like if you stepped on the court
right now he had hold your own with uh
with somebody just shooting oh yeah yeah
I mean you know a lot of people think
that it just goes away I'll do it
everyday but you know people have to
remember as years and years and years
and years of buildup you got millions of
hours so you know I'm actually going
into the gym there's more you'll get a
workout in if you know if you shot
threes against D Wade and LeBron right
now baby
they probably beat me because they've
been in the gym more okay but I could
make it a good game alright talk enough
you know you know older guys talk about
you know just to be there at the end
that's that would be my role yeah but
those guys are old they're veterans that
you can't get in their head you're not
going to talk junk to them hey can I
might as well try you know I mean if
we're playing a shooting game I know I
won't be able to beat it without it so
I'm carry out the Big B I'm curious
about your thoughts with James Harden in
particular on defending him and and
officiating him I don't know what's
tougher officiating James Harden or
defending James Harden I think it kind
of goes both um you know I was watching
the game yesterday and it's kind of been
that dynamic all season especially you
know what the Warriors to but especially
with James you know that step-back three
is a pretty you know good shot for him
all right right he's probably the best
that's ever you know John that type of
shot before but every time he shoots the
ball he falls you know it's a it's a
kind of um I saw one one move where
Chris Paul cut a shot and leaned into it
did he get fouled yeah but if you kind
of you know
jerk and react you know you're asking
the referees to make you know dozens of
calls you know per game in that split
decision so naturally they're gonna miss
up but yeah it's difficult to guard that
guy and it's difficult to officiate it's
kind of these unorthodox is weird it's
different but it's effective and you
know he draws contact and you know you
have to figure out a way to kind of you
know officiate it correctly but it's not
easy
how would you guard him I think I think
one of the interesting things guys seems
to doing I watched in a jazz series
they're really really corralling that
left hand and they're corralled in a
three-point line so that's kind of an
interesting thing no matter how far he
steps back they stay on that left hand
and force him force him to put the ball
on the floor and drive you know so he's
gonna have to you know continue to drive
and then we kick you to the other
teammate they're gonna have to make
plays you know but before they really
get it going if they want to win Game
two they probably need to you know get
some production out of there other guys
and you know he's gonna have to figure
out a way to try it you know evade that
escape that they're you know or escape
that defensive strategy that people
starting to use on tougher to guard
though Harden Yanis Durant I guess we
can you can come on in there Oh Katie
yeah Katie man I mean yeah if you if you
watch him play I mean for one he's got a
few weapons he's got some guys he can
pass it to that can knock down a shot
and he's an excellent passer but any
seven feet you know and then he can
handle like a guard and then he can rise
and shoot he's got everything in between
game he's got the post up game he has so
many different facets to his game and
that's why I would give him the edge
because not only is he facing up and
running pick and rolls
it'll roll to the basket he'll get in
the post turnaround jumpers one dribble
pull-up 2g will pull up three standstill
jumpers you know he pretty much gives
you everything but the kitchen sink you
know and and and that doesn't make it
easy
not dead not that it's easy his game is
more face-up game he's very rarely gonna
take it to the post
he's very rarely gonna you know go for
to gerbil one dribble pull ups and stuff
like that so I give the educate he
because of the dynamics in this game
where would you now we it feels like
people are waiting to Chris and Kevin
Durant is the best player and it feels
like it almost we passed by Durant now
we went to the Greek freak who is the
best player in basketball today such a
we're quite you know III don't know why
you know people are very very you know I
guess important question is it something
I mean there's so many good players you
know and then when you get to the top
five in the league MVP race stuff like
that you know I will say that somebody
that doesn't get better just do it
Damian Lillard nobody's gonna talk about
Damian Lillard you know even after the
performance that he had in round one
after being disappointed last year you
know in the front I'm sorry in the
playoffs last year and not performing up
your standards you know to me so you
know LeBron James hell yeah he honest um
Dan Willard I wouldn't try to pick one
because it's kind of um you know I'm
trying to pick one person but I would go
with those those pool of guys are the
upper echelon of the league right now
but if you were starting your team and
you had the first pick if I started my
team and I had the first pick I would
probably I mean I'm a big so I'm a Goa
size and you so I would definitely go
with Yanis we're talking about you know
just just be honest advocate oh yeah
we're talking to Chris Bosh the former
Miami Heat forward do you remember your
last game that was what 2016 yeah 2016
against Thursday night against San
Antonio how did you do on TNT tonight I
think I maybe had 16 18 points they
thought this pretty good it was one of
those right before all-star games and
nobody you know we didn't really have a
focus and
concentration inspires be the grace off
of us that guy I think I have one nice
dunk i had a nice dunk and and that was
about it what's your favorite Miami Heat
story on or off the court he would
definitely be off the court we had so
much fun off the court man I mean I
think a lot of people you know are kind
of curious with that but most people
kind of see um you know everything on TV
and you anticipate that it's a fun time
it's not always fun playing games high
pressure high stakes you know but I
would say definitely off the court
because it was so many instances where
you know guys you know they needed
breakthroughs we have so many dinners so
many laughs you know just enjoy so much
time around each other
off the court that you know that became
some of our favorite times at least mine
do who's funnier waiter LeBron LeBron
like practical jokes he's pretty funny
you know this is a guy I could just you
know tell jokes and make funny
situations out of anything or you know
talk about current events is just things
that happened yesterday just naturally
you know naturally a funny person and
you know he loves to laugh as well but
you know that was and then like I said I
was a part of my favorite teams too
because you know Braun's funny but to
d-22 and then ray is funny and Rashard
Lewis is funny Mario Chalmers is funny
and we all just kinda you know get
together and try to see who tells the
best joke sometimes but it's um you know
he's pretty pretty funny I give it I
enjoy you know going to the gym going to
work every day we had Shaq's probably
the goofiest of all of them and he he's
great yeah he's pretty funny I mean I've
gotten a chance to work with Shaq on TNT
and stuff and you know he's one of those
guys that just don't stop hey you know
he's gonna keep on going until you laugh
at something didn't he used to run
around I I had somebody tell me that he
when he was with Cleveland he would he
would hug people naked he would run out
the locker room and he would hug people
did you hear that store you lucky for
you crazy you know what would you rather
do coach or be a GM is it like one of
those choice things I rather be a GM
because you can fire the coach so then
the cousin experience would kind of be
you know overrated a little bit if you
just get fired by your boss you know
what I mean but um yeah I would I would
rather be a GM not that you know is
different I mean I love you know the
aspect of coaching I probably won't be a
coach probably never will be a coach but
you know the GM that's kind of a
different chess game it's a different
it's a huge difference and you know like
I said before yeah you can you can you
got a little bit more authority so and I
always joke as I said I'll never coach
because you know man is tough closing
professional athletes you know and
they're when they're making more money
than you are that that you know dynamic
of communication it's very very very
different you know so I'm aware of that
Chris good to catch up with you hope
you're feeling well and good luck in the
media if that's where you decide to end
up I appreciate that man that's a Chris
Bosh former Miami Heat forward had to
retire at the age of 31 had a blood clot
condition he did okay though
got a couple of titles probably a Hall
of Famer and I think he made some coin
as well if you missed any of our
celebrity interviews this week from the
mercedes-amg man cave go to the Dan
Patrick app where you can watch and
listen from inside the mercedes-amg man
cave mercedes-amg driving performance
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on VR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app